David Kennedy author of freedom from
fear you say in the introduction that
you went to a number of battlefields
thank you some veterans tell us about
that well I went to the most memorable
of those trips actually was to
Guadalcanal in the Solomon Islands which
is a very difficult place to reach
physically it's not on the usual tourist
track but I took a group of mostly
Stanford alumni down there and I gave
some lectures on World War Two we had a
group of maybe 75 or 80 people and about
a dozen or two of those were veterans of
the Solomon Islands campaign and that
was a real education we'd stand on these
airfields and they would describe how
they crash-landed or how they watched
somebody crash land and how they aldo
for the bunkers when the japanese planes
came over and so on it was it was quite
an education where else did you go well
with that group we went to a Guadalcanal
itself and Sabo sound of course which is
right there Tuilagi which is right
across Sabo Sound and then around the
solomon chain a bit we wanted to go to
Bougainville but that was there was
political unrest we couldn't get in then
I went with another group a few years
earlier to Anzio and Salerno in Italy
and then I went with a group to Normandy
about well I was actually I was in the
50th anniversary of the d-day summer is
1944 1994 what happens to a writer when
you get to see those places up close
especially when you wrote this book well
you know I wrote a book earlier on the
first world war and I made a point of
walking all the all the major American
battlefields from World War one just to
get a physical sense of what they look
like and what it must have felt like to
be there in combat these World War two
trips actually that I just mentioned
were a little bit different because not
only was I trying to get the sense of
the physical locale which is sort of my
first objective but I had the added
bonus of having these these veterans
with me and hearing their war stories so
it was a kind of a compound thing I got
not I was able to soak up not only the
physical landscape but a lot of the
psychological landscape the landscape of
memory as well but it's I think it's
indispensable for a writer about these
kinds of military topics to to know the
terrain it's so it's so important to
understand
how the action unfolds 936 pages yes how
long did it take you took me 11 years to
finish this book how'd you do it and
what's in it somebody's not heard about
it not seen it
what would they get well they'd get a
pretty complete history of the Great
Depression and the New Deal and World
War 2 those are the three big topics the
working title for the book when I first
went to work on it was simply the New
Deal and I think actually in the
publishers mind they they understood
that as the core subject in fact as the
work on it unfolded more than half the
book is about World War two you I want
to ask you about some people you started
off by talking about four men and you
end it talking about four men mm-hmm why
don't we go through them and tell us a
little bit about what you think of them
well the very first the historical
character who appears in the scene in
this book is Adolf Hitler and I was able
to locate where he where Hitler and
Winston Churchill and Franklin Roosevelt
and Joseph Stalin where they all were at
the moment they heard of the end of
World War one in 1918 November 1918 and
that the discussion of those four people
and where they were actually as a fifth
but I couldn't quite get him physically
located but I get him in the scene and
the prologue is Fuma Morel Kanoa who's
the last peacetime the civilian Prime
Minister of Japan 1941 they constitute
the discussion in the prologue because
I'm trying to set the scene in the
readers mind that there that World War
one was an immense perturbation of the
international environment a great
disruption and it's against the backdrop
of that lingering disruption that all
this subsequent history will play out
the history of the depression the
history of the New Deal and of course
the great sequel to World War one which
is world war two and I did that
deliberately because the the next big
long patch of the book doesn't look at
the international scene very much at all
but I wanted to establish firmly in the
readers mind from the outset that this
history takes place in the context of a
greatly disrupted international
environment and then I come back to them
all at the end although some of them are
dead by 1945 fact the only one who's
alive and in power in 1945 is Joseph
Stalin and he in a sense closes out the
book as a way of reminding the reader
that another period of great
international tension was to follow
which is the Cold War so this the title
of this book freedom from fear captures
what I think is the essential
accomplishment of this generation that
they diminished elements of fear and
uncertainty in the life of this society
in the life of American individuals but
they didn't banish all fear from all
human history and there was still there
were still problems to follow where was
Adolf Hitler at the end of World War one
well he was in a recovering in a
hospital in Passau Valcke in eastern the
eastern part of Germany and he'd been
gassed in the later phase of the war by
by the British British attack and the
the gas attack had temporarily blinded
him so he was invalided out to this
recovery facility away in the eastern
side of Germany and he was in a hospital
with a lot of other recovering war
wounded and a chaplain came to tell him
and the other men that the the German
government had surrendered even while
the German army was more or less still
intact in the field and though there's
some controversy about the reliability
of Hitler's memory of this moment it's
more or less the moment when he and
others begin to think that they'd been
betrayed by their civilian leadership
this is the great stab in the back
they're enormous ly resentful of the the
wastefulness of the their sacrifice and
the sacrifice of their comrades in arms
and if not precisely at that moment
certainly shortly thereafter Hitler sets
himself on the track of trying to avenge
this great injustice to the German
veterans and of the German people and
there's no question I think that he's
the first character in the book for good
reason because in throughout this whole
period between the end of World War one
and the conclusion of World War two he's
the single actor who more than anybody
else drives the action and disrupts the
scene and World War two was his war I
think to a disproportionate degree
Churchill is sorry I just want to ask
you one thing about it I feel her you
referenced the first book you referenced
is mine count how many and then in the
bibliography in the back there lots of
books how many books do you think you
read
to prepare yourself to write this book
well the numbers in the hundreds I
couldn't tell you I never did an exact
count but there is an enormous
literature you know about the history of
the interwar period about the the onset
of the depression the New Deal World War
two in fact I do not claim to have read
every single thing written about those
matters but yeah I did a lot of reading
and it took 11 years to put this
together and in this book is it all from
secondary sources or primary search no
it's almost all from published sources
but by this point in time a lot of what
we would call primary sources are
published for example the Churchill
Roosevelt correspondence in a wonderful
edition edited by Warren Kimble is in
three volumes is beautifully reproduced
and annotated and a very reliable
primary source though you can find it
too between two covers and published
form this this great series Foreign
Relations of the United States which the
State Department publishes is another
primary source but you don't have to go
to an archive to get it you can get it
between bernabéu between covers in your
own University Libraries so there's a
lot of that kind of material in there
but I did virtually no archival research
for this book it's not that that was not
my intention the the idea of the Oxford
history of the United States in which
series this is a volume is a series that
was originally conceived by Richard
Hofstadter and C Vann Woodward some
years ago the idea of the series is to
bring two general readers not just two
specialists and not certainly not just a
captive student audiences to bring to
them the best the current scholarship
and but to make it in an accessible form
in a narrative form so the general
reader can get it
and that meant distilling the best of
this rather considerable body of
literature into an accessible account
for the general reader just showing a
volume three four five and ten no your
volume is nine actually is this and it's
it's three let me just back up why did
you list here volume 3 volume 6 volume 9
and volume 10 well the answer simple
there are nine or ten actually projected
volumes in the series eventually when
it's finished but they have not been
published in chronological order the
first volume published
was about the American Revolution it's
about Robert middlecoff called the
glorious cause the second volume
published was about the Civil War by
James McPherson battle cry of freedom
it's called third volume published was
grand expectations by James Patterson
which covers the period from the end of
World War two down to the early 1970s
the fourth volume published was mine
this book freedom from fear but it
obviously covers a chronological period
earlier than the last book that was
published so it just depends on when the
various authors in the series have
managed to get their work done how are
you picked to be the author of this
period well the general editors of the
series are sheldon Meyer of the editor
at Oxford press and C Vann Woodward the
Dean of all American Historians age 91
but still going strong a great southern
historian they asked me to have to write
this book and it was an offer I couldn't
refuse what were you doing when they
asked you originally when they
originally asked me I just finished
writing this book about the first world
war called over here and actually I can
prove this because it's in the the
preface the the for matter to that book
I said something in the last sentence of
the preface to that book about how the
first world war is but a prelude to a
far greater war generation later but
that's another story for telling another
time so I already had it in my head to
do something with the Second World War
and then they came and said would you do
this volume on the new deal in world war
ii and i said well it's a bit more than
I was anticipating in terms of the range
of the subject but sure if you're in my
business which is the history of the
United States in the 20th century which
is what I mostly concern myself with
there's no question that these two
events the depression World War two are
the most deeply formative events in
history of this society I dare say in
the history of global society in this
century and I just couldn't pass up an
opportunity to have a good long go with
this what do you do full time full time
my day job as they say is I history at
Stanford University what years what
years later the students yeah oh I teach
everything from freshman to postdocs
that's that's the way Stanford works and
how long have you done that I've been
teaching at Stanford
32 years since 1967 let me ask you a
political question because you might
remember that C Vann Woodward was one of
the three historians that led the group
of 400 that opposed the idea of P Qing
impeaching President Clinton were you
involved in that if I sign that letter
yes
does that worry you that when you get
involved in politics like that that
people might you know react politically
to you when you do a history book like
this no not really I really think
well let me say another reason why I
left it the chance to do this book in
this series is because I've long
believed and I was a student of
Woodward's I should probably say truth
and disclosure back in the 60s so I
probably learned some of this from him
but I do believe that it's part of the
the civic responsibility of historians
to be part of the public discourse of
their time and to speak responsibly out
of whatever they think they understand
about the past about the present I just
think that's a responsibility we have as
historians so I signed that letter about
the Clinton impeachment because I my own
view was that the impeachment remedy was
wildly disproportionate to the offense
and that was that that's that's full
stop that's that's the that was the
nature of my belief about the matter and
that's what prompted me to sign the
letter sure some people object to that
kind of taking that kind of position but
that goes with the territory I don't
think we should shrink from expressing
ourselves just because somebody might
object what do you think of FDR well
I'll tell you a story about that I think
FDR is a very great historical figure
but this the subtitle of this book is
the American people in depression and
war and I'm quite insistent on the the
explanatory value of that subtitle a few
years ago I was teaching at Oxford
University in England and I had the
great privilege of meeting Sir Isaiah
Berlin and a moment that was very
flattering to me when we were introduced
he he professed to know something about
me he said oh you're the person that's
writing this new biography of Franklin
Roosevelt well he had a little wrong
nice to know sir eyes I in fact I'm not
writing the biography of Franklin
Roosevelt I'm writing a general history
of the American people during
the Great Depression and World War two
and I said in fact as a writer it's a
problem for me not to succumb to the
enormous charm of Roosevelt's historical
personality and turn it into a biography
against my better judgment and as I
Berlin grabbed my arm and fixed me with
a gaze in the eye and he said oh my boys
succumb succumb because he thought the
Roosevelt was such a great world
historical figure that it was the proper
way to tell the story of this time was
the story of his engagement with these
events but that's not I tried not to do
that in the book though necessarily
Roosevelt is the dominant personality of
this era there's no in the history of
this country at least there's no
question about it and he does figure
quite prominently in the book you called
Herbert Hoover and the early part of the
book a great humanitarian and take a
take on him that I think those that have
you know a simple image would probably
be surprised would you say well a lot of
people have been a lot of reviewers have
seized on this as a surprising element
at the book in fact I go back to the
purpose of this series which is to bring
the best and recent and current
scholarship to a general public it's no
surprise to most professional students
of this matter that Hoover's reputation
in folklore has been badly distorted so
my fellow professional historians I
think would not find this so surprising
we've long since come to the conclusion
that Hoover got a bad rap and a lot of
the standard accounts and the great
humanitarian was what he was called
popularly and publicly after his effort
during World War one to organize
international relief for occupied
Belgium German occupied Belgium and he
as I view him and a lot of other people
view him he was quite a personal quite
advanced views for his era he was no old
laissez-faire 19th century style
conservative he meant to use the
presidency actively and he did in fact
but he got swamped by the scale of the
depression and by his own political
ineptitude eventually and now I think of
Hoover is something of a tragic figure a
person of rather considerable creativity
and energy and great intelligence who
has just overcome by events that are
beyond his control
back to we were talking about mine calm
for a moment if you read mine comp back
in and what year did it come out well
1924 give or take a year it's it's the
early 20s say you've got Hitler after
the 1918 after World War one writing
mine Kampf if you read that then what's
in there that would tip you off as to
where he was headed is it all there well
you know among the people that read it
early on was Franklin Roosevelt he read
it well before Hitler came to power and
it convinced him that as he said Hitler
is a madman but neither he nor anybody
else I think could anticipate just how
influential this madman would be I think
they regarded him at first as an
aberration when he came to power
but then he closed his fist over the
entire apparatus of government in
Germany and made the whole country
subservient to his will and made more
trouble for the world than anybody could
anticipate go through the other man
universe turns out about Winston
Churchill where was he after World War
one well Churchill because he's such a
wonderful writer and a great documentary
of his own life he's the one that was
the easiest to fix in time most reliably
we know precisely where he was he was in
his office in London looking down into a
street below and he knew that Big Ben
was going to ring the chimes at 11 a.m.
on November 11th 1918 the famous 11th
hour of the 11th month and so on and on
the eleventh day of the eleventh month
and he records in his his own memoirs
how he looked down into the street and
first he saw one girl all by herself
come out of a storefront or an office
building into the street and then
suddenly hundreds of other people poured
out of these buildings and Alston
celebrated the end of the war and then
he tells us what he was thinking at this
moment and of course the first thing he
was thinking was how glad he was that it
was all over but he also says that I
quote this in the book he said that's
not something the effect that a and
knell rang in the ears of the victors
even in this moment of celebration
because he knew that the the war did not
settle all the problems that had caused
it and in the future most likely held
the considerable trouble so his is in a
sense the most prophetic tragic view of
what the the next couple of decades will
hold he he
knows that the world the world's
problems are not solved by the piece of
their side what was he doing then he was
a minister in the British government so
he was Member of Parliament Yes Minister
remember part Lizzy would be of course
to hold a ministerial post where was FDR
FDR was Assistant Secretary of the Navy
and in fact just weeks before the
Armistice or months before the Armistice
he had traveled to the the front in
France and made a tour of a whirlwind
tour of the battlefield he later
referred to that quite often
particularly in the presidential
campaign of 1940 when he would
repeatedly say I have seen war I know
what war can do I hate war well that was
kind of true he'd seen some very safe
areas of the front he had not really
been exposed to any particular danger
but he had seen some of the destruction
of the first world war in France and so
on but on November 11th 1918 of course
he was in Washington DC and actually
it's not he but the Eleanor who records
in her autobiographical writing how they
felt at the moment of the Armistice how
what a celebration had caused and so on
but we also know that Franklin Roosevelt
had just a few weeks earlier actually a
few days earlier gone to Woodrow Wilson
and asked if he could please resign his
cabinet posts as assistant secretary of
the Navy and take a commission in the
Navy and actually go to war as a
military officer and Wilson told him
it's too late the war was virtually over
the negotiations are so far advanced
that the system matter of days or weeks
so that would be futile so Roosevelt
never had a uniform military career and
what about this polio had he had polio
you know the polio comes a few years
later when he's actually vacationing at
the family summer home at Campobello is
when it first presents itself and then
of course for most of the following
decade of the 1920s he spends trying to
have to recover and he he product again
of this indomitable rather phenomenal
willpower of his he continues and
persists in the belief that he will
recover much contrary to the best men
advice that he could get at that time
people did not recover from polio which
is what he had and he as we know we
never did regain the use of his legs
although he developed this capacity to
walk quote-unquote in a peculiar way in
this big heavy 10-pound steel braces on
his legs and he he learned to be able if
he could balance on something had a good
Sun somebody's arm he could throw one
hip forward then the other hip former he
had mobility above the waist and it was
a a version of a walk he could only do
it for a few paces he really couldn't
cover much ground with it and it was
quite awkward and lurching but it was
enough that he could present himself in
public as having at least partly
recovered and he could stand with if he
locked the knee device on the brace he
could stand it at a platform if he could
hold on to it and balance so he could
give a speech standing up so the fact
that he had been crippled was not
exactly a secret but the public was more
or less given to understand that he
defected at least a partial recovery
from this and he was careful in public
not to display himself in a wheelchair
or being physically lifted as he had to
be in and out of automobiles and so on
the only occasion that I know of when he
broke that discipline or that practice
was when he came back from Yalta in
early 1945 and he addressed the Congress
sitting down and he made a reference to
the fact that it's easier for me to sit
than to stand with ten pounds of steel
on my legs the best of my now is that's
the only public reference that he ever
made to his disability where was Joseph
Stalin right after World War one well
Joseph Stalin at the end of nineteen end
of World War one 1918 is old in the
nature of the case he being Stalin if
being revolutionary Russia he's a little
more difficult to place precisely but we
know just before November 11th 1918 he'd
been in the city that was then called
Tsaritsyn that's later called Stalingrad
still later called Volga Grug and he'd
been a commissar political commissar
there and his job was to punish
political enemies which he did by
murdering them probably at the moment of
the Armistice he was back in Moscow his
precise whereabouts were a little
elusive but he was clearly at that
moment one of the leaders of the
[ __ ]
revolution and part of his
responsibility was to extinguish as many
political opponents as he could get his
hands on as you know you say the primary
cause of the Great Depression reads the
first sentence of his memoirs was the
war of 1914 to 1918 the memoirs of
Herbert Hoover in her introduction talk
about the Versailles Treaty who was
there what did it say and what impact do
you think it had then on the Great
Depression and then on World War two
well the the big four negotiators of the
Versailles Treaty of course were the
American President Woodrow Wilson the
British Prime Minister Lloyd George the
the French premier Georges Clemenceau
and the Italian Premier of Victoria
Orlando Orlando was really a minor
player in this but he nevertheless he
had one of the so-called big four seats
that the Paris peace talks there the
negotiation actually takes place at
Paris the document is signed at their
size so we commonly call it the
Versailles Treaty the great product of
the negotiation particularly from the
American point of view in 1918 1919 was
that the all the signatories agreed to
create this new thing called the League
of Nations and of course Woodrow Wilson
was the great champion of creating this
new institution and then one of the
bitter ironies of the end of World War
one is that the American Senate rejects
the treaty that would have taken the
United States into the League of Nations
and the United States retreats rather
markedly from the kind of limited
tentative internationalism that Woodrow
Wilson had tried to promote so that's
the first big break down you might say
of the Treaty mechanism is that the
Americans refused to enter into the
League of Nations but you know the the
most penetrating analysis I think of the
Versailles Treaty ever written was
written in its immediate aftermath by a
British observer who was there for most
the negotiations the famous economist he
wasn't then quite as famous as it
becomes later john maynard keynes and a
wonderful book called the economic
consequences of the peace and the the
central argument of that book is where
cain says that the the Versailles Treaty
perpetuated in peacetime the greatest
economic and political crime of the war
which was the economic division of
Europe Europe before 1914 have been
quite
functionally unified Continental economy
lots of international trade and capital
flows and so on it really functioned as
a single economic unit to a considerable
degree the war disrupted all that and
then because of the the the punitive
measures imposed upon Germany by the
treaty reparations payments the the
suppressing of the German coal and steel
industry taking away from Germany
control over her own Inland Waterways
our own Merchant Marine taking away her
colonies all of these flowed from the
treaty Keynes said this this is an
insane perpetuation in peacetime of the
economic disruptions of the war by
formal treaty arrangement and he
predicted that the war would the treaty
would sow the seeds of another war and
he was absolutely right I want to jump
way out of context here because as you
know in 936 pages we could have a 14
hour interview easily because I wanted
you to talk about someone named arena
Hickok and you talk about her trip
around the United States her eyes and
ears for president FDR Eleanor Roosevelt
she in Doris Kearns Goodwin told us
about her living on the second floor of
the White House who was she
and why did you talk about her new book
well let me answer that directly but let
me just back up a step because it was as
a writer about the depression in the New
Deal it was a structural problem for me
to avoid doing what I think most writers
have done and that is about this issue
and that is to describe the depression
to describe Hoover's failed attempt to
deal with it then to bring wrote
Franklin Roosevelt on stage and the
implication is that at that moment
everything is hunky-dory again and we're
on the road to recovery in fact the
depression persists until 1940 or even
1941 and in by some measures rather
obvious measures in fact Franklin
Roosevelt is no more successful in
licking the depression than was Herbert
Hoover unemployment rate never goes
below 14 percent and all the to
Roosevelt New Deal administration's so
when I was writing the book
I progressed through the prologue and
the this scene that where I set the
scene in the 1920s and the Hoover
administration the onset of the
Depression but I not yet painted any
human face with it what the actual human
impact of the Depression was and both of
the editors both Vann Woodward and
shelled admirer
got on my back about what where's the
where's the human suffering of the
depression and my response was I'm
deliberately waiting till we get well
into the 1930s into the Roosevelt
administration to describe that because
I want to make the point that the
depression persists and I don't want the
reader to get the idea that the
depression is a Hoover problem and then
Roosevelt solves it so I wanted to wait
until 1930 four or five in the
chronological account before I really
rendered for the reader what the
depression looked like Lorena Hickok
served my purposes beautifully because
she was a reporter one of the few really
prominent women news reporters of the
era who got very close to Eleanor
Roosevelt during the presidential
campaign of 1932 she was assigned to
cover
Eleanor during the campaign in a sense
she lost her professional journalistic
objectivity it became more of a flack
for Eleanor Roosevelt than a reporter
and it became impossible for her to work
as an objective journalist any longer so
Eleanor got her a job let me stop and
ask you though what kind of power did
she have working for the Associated
Press and writing about the president to
be and Eleanor Roosevelt well as I say
she was most women reporters women
journalists in that era were
conventionally assigned to the feature
page and they read the wrote the society
column or what have you
she was not she covered hard news
stories and she was one of the principal
reporters on the
the Lindbergh kidnapping case for
example so she had quite a national
reputation as a hard-nosed reporter in
any case Eleanor Roosevelt gets her a
job as a kind of roving field reporter
for Harry Hopkins the chief federal
relief administrator in the New Deal and
her assignment isn't simply to drive
around the country and right back to
Hopkins what it looked like out there
and how these relief programs were
working or not working and because she's
such a skilled reporter and a
wonderfully observant reporter and
writes so well she served my purposes
just wonderfully as somebody who in the
mid 30s not in the early 30s not in the
Hoover years but in the Roosevelt years
is documenting just how god-awful the
depression is up there and she drove
particularly around the the Upper
Midwest and the South were the two
regions she spent the most time in but
also the Northeast and even the Far West
so it was it was the timing of when
she's writing that that's part of what
appealed to me it was her skill as a
reporter and an observer which appealed
to me and then there's another thing
about her which appealed to me and that
is that she something happens to her
when she's out on the road in Depression
America she comes to an understanding
that what she's looking at the misery
that she's looking at is not simply just
the result of the depression that she's
looking at the accumulated misery and
suffering of generations of wild
unregulated industrial revolution that
she's looking at what I called the book
the old poor not just a depression poor
and that she understand she comes to an
understanding that the issues that have
to be addressed here are not just relief
from the depression but really some
far-reaching structural reform that will
deal with the accumulated problems of a
century's worth of unbridled Industrial
Revolution in the United States so for
all these reasons she just served my
purpose is wonderfully well when did she
get so close to Eleanor Roosevelt that
she moved into the second floor well I
couldn't date that for you precisely off
the top of my head but yeah they she and
Eleanor become very very close there's
at least one biographer of Eleanor
Roosevelt Blanche cook who suggests
doesn't quite say but suggests that they
may have had a even an intimate physical
relationship I think the evidence on
that
frankly is is dubious to say the least
it's possible but I kind of dove it what
about it you know a lot of our viewers
and we hear them through our : shows are
suspicious of reporters being too
involved too close to the political
system what's your experience when you
read back in those days where reporters
as close as Lorena Hickok and a
cheerleading FDR well Lorena Hickok is
an extreme example in the sense because
she had to give up any pretense of
objective journalism and went to work
for the White House you might say but in
fact if if it's true and I think it is
substantially true that the press has in
the last half century or so moved into
some worrisome lis intimate relationship
with the people of on whom it reports
the political establishment to the
ascent that's true we can trace the the
roots of this to a large degree right
back to the New Deal because Franklin
Roosevelt I think very shrewdly and very
cleverly co-opted a lot of the working
press he did in his first week in the
White House he summoned the Washington
press corps into the Oval Office and
regaled them with stories and kind of
false intimacy's and cut them in on all
kinds of background information told him
he was changing the rules for
presidential press conferences it was a
practice before them that they had to
submit questions in advance in writing
and the president could not be quoted
directly unless he gave Express
permission and so on
Roosevelt changed all that he said I'll
answer questions on the spot that's one
thing there was new and he said I will
also on occasion give you what he called
background information he said this will
not be for print you can't put it in
print it's just for your information so
that you'll understand the news better
well that's the masterstroke because
he's bringing them right into the giving
him the illusion at least they're
bringing them right into the circle of
power telling them he's going to give
them information that will make them
feel close to events though they can't
use it in print unless he tells him so
well they were right right in his hand
right there and a lot of more they're
ever after Roosevelt thought that in a
sense he had to do this he had to
somehow co-op tour or seduce you might
even say they're working press because
all the editorial staffs and the
publishers of the nation's major
newspapers were against him and indeed
that's largely true most
Torres example of that is the publisher
of the Chicago Tribune Robert McCormick
it was one of his great and flamboyant
adversaries so Roosevelt thought I'll
have to work in another level with the
actual working press I'll bring them
into my orbit because I'll never get the
editors and the publishers into my into
my orbit another thing again it's a
little bit out of context we hear in
civics class that the three different
branches of government there's a
definite separation for the Supreme
Court and the others but you tell a
story in here about Louis Brandeis
having an impact on the Social Security
bill in a strange way how did it happen
well Brandeis was of course on the
Supreme Court he's appointed earlier on
by Woodrow Wilson first Jew ever
appointed to the Supreme Court and
through his daughter and son-in-law he
made some key suggestions to the
drafters of the Social Security Act
about how they might contrive to avoid
what looked to be insurmountable
constitutional obstacles to putting the
federal government into the business of
unemployment relief it was on the
unemployment side unemployment insurance
side of the Social Security Act that he
that he intervened but yes and I think
you might say he skirted the very edges
of the boundaries of what was
permissible for a Supreme Court justice
to do in terms of intervening in the
legislative process he did it by
indirection to be sure but he did it
quite deliberately and purposely he
called these people to his house and and
he read them some Court decisions and he
glossed them for them they said now
here's where I think you can find the
proper loophole where you can draft
legislation that will pass judicial
muster so he was coaching the drafters
of the Social Security Act and how they
could avoid being voided by the Supreme
a Supreme Court decision where did you
find all that is it obvious that
information actually I off top my head I
don't remember precisely where I found
that account but it's again I didn't
excavate it out of the archives it's
other writers have written about it I
think it's maybe I've got Elliott
recollections of the New Deal as a
footnote on that page well yes he's one
memoir so that's a wonderful memoir
actually Thomas L
it's memoir he was a young lawyer at
that time and one of the craftsmen the
the technicians drafting the Social
Security he yes you're right he's one
person that writes about it but there
are others but yes his was a very fresh
memoir it was published actually while I
was in 1984 I believe while I was
working on the book and that was very
instructive to me because it was such a
fresh first-person account of how the
Social Security Act got drafted how did
you get into this business in the first
place
where'd you where were you born I was
born in Seattle 1941 as I'm fond of
saying I'm a nod nod way a child of the
depression because my parents were
married in 1930 but couldn't afford to
start a family for until the depression
was over eleven years later which is
accounts for the date of my birth and it
also accounts for the fact that I have
no siblings what did they do
well my father when the depression came
he was working in a mining camp in the
Cascade Mountains in Washington state
and almost within a matter of weeks
after he married my mother in 1930 the
mining company he was working for went
bankrupt and this camp was in a very
very remote location in the North
Cascade Mountains in the wintertime
which lasted about seven months from
October till May or so it was a two-day
snowshoe trip out to a cleared road and
so it was rather a grim place to be and
for reasons that are a little obscure to
me the two of them ended up staying
there and what became a ghost town
for eight years my father had no cash
income until he went to work on a PWA
project at Grand Coulee Dam running a
grocery store
what's the PWA the Public Works
Administration that's one of the great
New Deal public works construction
agencies and then he eventually got a
job as a federal inspector of defense
contracts in the Puget Sound area that's
world war two cranked up and then then
he felt secure enough to to have me so
in that sense I think of myself as a
child of the depression where did you
grow up there then I grew up in Seattle
until I went away to college where'd you
go school well I went to college of the
place where I now teach at Stanford
University in California so you've been
at Stanford for how many years total
well my accumulated time at Stanford is
now I guess about 36 years but I went
away to graduate school
Yale in the 60s that's when I studied
with Vann Woodward and with my great
doctor father as we say John Blum who
was that person supervised my my
doctoral work the most what do you think
got you interested in history hmm
exid I can be quite specific about that
I when I I went to college originally
intending to be an electrical engineer
and went through much of the engineering
curriculum at Stanford and at a certain
point I took a history course a little
bit randomly from a absolutely marvelous
scholar and a truly remarkable human
being but I named a David Potter and
Potter the name of the course was the
American character and the problem at
the heart of this course was simply is
there such a thing as a distinctive
character to American society
historically construed can we really
speak responsibly about a some
distinctive aspects of American society
well that turns out to be a rich deep
analytical problem and powder was a
brilliant teacher and he kind of put
that problem on my agenda and got me
going in history and I've been with it
ever since and what when you went to put
this book together said to you 11 years
give us the physical place you do it and
how do you how do you keep track of all
this and what's your method of putting
words finally on paper well I'm not very
pleasant to live with but I'm writing
something on this scale I should say and
I'm sure my family would testify to that
effect my writing habit is to get up
early in the morning 6:00 a.m. or so and
to work for write for four or five hours
before I make myself fit for public
company for a shower or shave or
anything else so the morning is my
writing time and I just chain is a
metaphorically speaking chained myself
to the the desk and and write for four
or five hours some time years ago I read
that Ernest Hemingway could produce a
thousand words a day and he thought that
was a good solid consistent professional
writers pace if you could write a
thousand words a day day in and day
you're doing pretty darn well and
someplace along the line I internalized
that took that on board as my standard
and I I consider a successful day if I
can get out of thousand words
did you write more than the nine hundred
thirty six pages and have to cut it back
to be honest no in any real sense that
the publisher did when the final
manuscript came in expressed some worry
about the size of the book and they said
we'd like you to cut about a hundred
pages well I went back over and I
managed to cut about twelve pages so
it's not much shorter than what I
submitted but you know it's it's this
length for a good reason it's you can't
in my judgement you can't write
responsibly about events of this
magnitude and gravity without giving
them this kind of serious detailed
attention these were the great crises of
the century after all they made us who
we are as a people and as a country and
I think the story deserves to be told in
full near the middle somewhere this is
written as Churchill later explained to
his war cabinet Roosevelt quote said he
would wage war but not declare it and
that he would become more and more
provocative everything was to be done to
force an incident the president made it
clear that he would look for an incident
which would justify him in opening
hostilities
well Churchill at that moment is talking
about the Atlantic Christ and the there
were incidents on the Atlantic here's
the interesting mystery about this five
my memory is correct that remark is made
in like September of 1941 maybe August
of 1941 after the argenteum it's near
August you know at the conference that
were the Atlantic charters or Pearl
Harbor yes well before Pearl Harbor at
that time the the Americans the the
Roosevelt administration is trying to
decide whether or not or how it can
escort the merchant marine convoys that
are taking lend-lease goods to Britain
there's a lot of American munitions of
war material flowing to Britain but the
lend-lease act of March 1941 explicitly
prohibited American naval vessels from
escorting these merchant ships that were
carrying goods to Britain well there was
an obvious problem here because the
Congress had authorized the
asure of money and lend-lease to get the
goods to britain but then it stops short
of taking measures to ensure the goods
actually got there by protecting them
from German submarine attacks and
Roosevelt was turning every which way
looking for a legal means to get these
the ships protected so he did begin the
convoy through a lot of convoluted
devices declaring first Greenland and
then Iceland to be part of the Western
Hemisphere is arbitrarily said they're
part of the Western Hemisphere
therefore American ships can go out that
far without violating the provisions of
the lend-lease act that was an egregious
fiction but he did it anyway
and he expected it so did Churchill this
is what Churchill is referring to that
it's the at some point the Germans would
attack an American naval vessel and that
this could be used as an occasion for
Roosevelt to go to the Congress and ask
for a declaration of war which is
precisely what had happened in 1917 what
that was what Woodrow Wilson used as an
occasion to ask the Congress for a
declaration of war
was the German submarine sinkings of
American ships and February March of
1917 well in fact there are several
naval incidents that follow the Rueben
James the Carney the Greer are attacked
by German submarines in the fall of 1941
but Roosevelt does not use these
sinkings as an occasion it doesn't to
use Churchill's language he doesn't call
them an incident that demands that the
United States declare war on Germany so
there's there's a puzzle here about why
Roosevelt still at this late date is
hesitating actually to use one of these
incidents to go to war with Germany the
answer seems to be that he's not ready
for war wouldn't have done any good to
declare war because he doesn't have an
army to fight with and he doesn't have
much of a Navy either at this moment so
what good was a declaration of war do it
would just unleash the Germans to
undertake absolutely unrestricted
attacks on American ships but the United
States didn't have much capacity to
throw a counter punch at that point I
picked up on some words that you use
that's why I'm reading these different
areas quote I tell you the blunt fact
that the German submarine fired first
upon this American destroyer without
warning and with deliberate design to
sinker unquote the president
misleadingly said yes well yes that's
Franklin Roosevelt they're in a public
description he was describing to the
American people this attack on the Greer
I believe it's in September of 1941 and
he rendered that to the public as if it
were an unprovoked attack by a German
submarine on an American destroyer the
story the actual story is a lot more
complicated than that and not as simple
as Roosevelt painted and he knew better
he knew the facts of the matter the the
American destroyer had actually made
sonar contact with a German submarine
and radioed the position of the
submarine to a British attack plane
which had torpedoes that could have
dropped it could drop from the air onto
the submarine and the American destroyer
held position relative to the German
submarine for several hours and tracked
it as it moved so that it could continue
reporting the position to this German
partner British plane
the British plane actually dropped some
airborne torpedoes on the submarine did
no damage the German submarine for
evidently good reason believed that it
was under attack from the Greer from the
American destroyer so fired back on the
Greer and that didn't hit it or didn't
do any damage considerable damage and
Roosevelt in his public account omitted
entirely the fact that the American
destroyer had made the first contact
with the submarine had radioed its
position to the British aircraft that
the British aircraft had dropped the
aerial torpedoes and that's why the
German submarine had attack and it
appears there that he was trying to do
what he what Churchill reported that he
was going to do to use this as an
incident that would be sufficiently he
could render it to the public and
sufficiently provocative that he could
then ask Congress for a declaration of
war but he doesn't do that he doesn't
ask for the declaration of war again I
think because in reality he had enough
good sense to realize that he had
nothing to gain at that moment from a
declaration of war the great American
contribution to the war effort was going
to be the output of its industrial
economy and it was still mobilizing for
the war and there was no reason to
disrupt that process at that point the
next page you say Roosevelt's prolonged
indecision and his ultimate deviousness
and implementing the escort policy have
exercised generations of critic
how devious was he threw his whole four
terms or three terms plus a few days
well the greer episode i think is
probably the most famously documented
bit of deception and misleading the
american public the more famous episode
or the more of a sensational episode
where he's frequently accused of
deception of course is the Pearl Harbor
attack but the reality is that there's
never been a scintilla of credible
evidence brought to bear or brought
forward to persuasively to argue that
Roosevelt knew in advance about the
attack on Pearl Harbor and certainly not
that he contrived to have that happen
but you know we have to remember he was
dealing here with a public and with a
Congress that had repeatedly made clear
its isolationist commitments and it's
its deep desire not to get drawn in to
this European conflict Roosevelt I think
early on and I think as early as 1935
began to understand that the United
States had somehow to find a way to put
its weight in the scales to check
aggression particularly Nazi aggression
in Europe and Japanese aggression in
Asia but the Congress in the country did
not necessarily agree with that in fact
they rather deliberately disagreed with
it
so Roosevelt's much of Roosevelt's
effort is present from 1935 right down
to the end of 1941 at Pearl Harbor is a
you might say a presidential civics
campaign to educate the American public
and through the public the Congress
about the necessity to break out of this
isolationist mold and somehow to to play
a part in the in this international
scene I wrote down a bunch of dates one
after another January of 2019 45 FDR
inaugurated for the fourth time February
the Yalta Conference April the 12th FDR
dies April the 28th benito mussolini
shot April the 30th two days later
Hitler shoots himself May 8 1945 the
war's over
how did thorn Europe is over yeah but
how do they deal with it back then all
those things happening one after another
what was what did you find in the media
when you went back there and looked at
well you know the remarkable thing I
suppose is that and you might have added
that shortly thereafter the Churchill
government is
rearranged in England Churchill's out of
power by July of 1945 in the middle of
the Potsdam Conference Churchill is has
to give up his chair and Clement Attlee
becomes the new Prime Minister and sits
in it the remarkable thing is that in
all the all the great belligerent states
on both sides victors and losers alike
the only state that maintains a kind of
evidence of political continuity is
Russia the Soviet Union Stalin stays in
power the United States has a new
president Britain has a new premier and
German the whole German system is
smashed the Japanese system is smashed
the Italian system is smashed and out of
this you might say diplomatic and
political rubble people are obliged to
reconstruct the world it's really quite
extraordinary that they did it as well
as they did and these absolutely chaotic
circumstances and near the end I want to
read what you also wrote when you're
talking about about 1945 and FDR you say
that how poorly Franklin Roosevelt had
prepared for the post-war era how
foolishly he had banked on goodwill and
personal charm to compose the
conflicting interests of nations how
little he had taken his countrymen into
his confidence even mislead them how
much how often did he mislead his
countrymen well I what I'm referring to
there especially is the I think rather
Pollyannish message that he repeatedly
told the American public that the
post-war era would be an era of
cooperation between the Western Allies
Britain and the United States and the
Soviet Union what he was hoping for was
somehow domesticating Joe Stalin and
bringing the Soviet Union into the
family of Nations making it behave
itself as a responsible international
partner but in no way did he prepare the
public for the kind of confrontation
with the Soviet Union that forms what we
know to what's known to history as the
Cold War there was no no hint publicly
from Roosevelt that there might be
difficulty in this relationship however
we also know that in inside the grand
alliance that's Britain the United
States and the Soviet Union
there's one strong unmistakable signal
of the fact that Roosevelt understood
that there was likely to be trouble in
that relationship after the war and
that's the fact that he
quite deliberately and repeatedly
refused to share with the Soviets the
secret of the Manhattan Project the
atomic bomb project that's a Brit as an
anglo-american project the British in
fact early on in the war came to
Roosevelt and said you know we think the
terms of our treaty relationship with
the Soviet Union require us to tell them
that we're working on this weapons
project and Roosevelt and Roosevelt
administration's say oh no if you if you
tell if you insist on telling the
Soviets we're gonna cut you the British
out of the project we'll do it all
ourselves you say that Harry Truman
walked up to Joseph Stalin oh he walked
up to me now if you say that he not
silently said hey by the way we have a
new weapon and that Joseph Stalin just
kind of tossed it off him and pay
attention well yes that's that's a
moment he did walk up to literally
walked up to him at Potsdam in July of
1945 it's a moment that has long puzzled
historians because there's a lot of the
preparatory work for the Potsdam meeting
in which Truman is quite clearly
thinking how we can use this the fact
that the United States now has a
successfully demonstrated nuclear device
because he gets news of the successful
test of the first atomic device at
Alamogordo New Mexico during the Potsdam
Conference and he has clearly been
thinking how can I use this to get some
leverage on the Soviets or as he puts it
in his own Missouri vernacular how can I
get a hammer on those boys he says and
then the moment comes when he can raise
the hammer or use the weapon in some way
diplomatically and he doesn't he rather
casually tells Stalin about this and
this has been a puzzle for a lot of
historians to try to figure out why it
was that Truman failed to use the the
atomic weapon as a diplomatic lever over
the Soviets at Potsdam
why so much made of the atomic bomb in
comparison with what you discuss here I
don't mean you do they'll often in
history does of dropping the atomic bomb
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki and not as
much attention on the Tokyo raids which
killed how many people
well the the fire raids on Japan the
faribault all of Japan what Henry
Stimson later said what we now call
conventional bombing that is pre nuclear
killed nearly a million Japanese before
that the atomic bombs were dry
and one single raid on Tokyo the night
of March 9th 10th 1945 a single fire
raid killed 100,000 people in one night
that's nearly double that people killed
at Nagasaki and something which is about
60,000 and approaches the number killed
at Hiroshi Shima which is 130 hundred
and forty thousand so the point I make
in the book is that there's there's
great drama attached to the two nuclear
attacks the Hiroshima and Nagasaki
bombings but they represent no kind of
crossing of a moral threshold they
represent a technological novelty the
more efficient the instrument of mass
destruction but the moral threshold I
argue had been crossed a long time
before if by moral threshold we mean
that the frank acceptance of the tactic
of mass slaughter of civilians as a way
to bring the enemy to his knees that was
precisely what we were trying to do with
the fire bombing of Japan in the first
five or six or seven months of 1945
before the nuclear weapons became
available and I don't think there's much
moral distinction between being
incinerated in the hundreds of thousands
by napalm which is what we were dropping
in Japan earlier in 1945 or being
incinerated by a nuclear blast you say
that that FDR gave the shortest Naugle
dress in history the fourth one 573
words and then you say that that he knew
for 10 months before he died that he had
a serious heart problem what do you
think of that that he knew that and that
the doctors knew that and that he went
to Yalta and went through all that
process well you know Roosevelt once
said when he was a much younger man he
said no man who has tasted public life
will ever willingly give it up and I
think he was really married to the idea
of himself as the the first citizen of
the United States and the the president
of the United States and it was just
psychologically I think impossible for
him to give that up I think it was
irresponsible of him to run for a fourth
term he knew he was ill some of his
intimate associates knew he was ill and
yet he persisted and to compound the
irresponsibility he paid the most
minimum kind of attention to who would
be most likely his successor the
he must have understood he could not
help to understand but whoever was his
vice-presidential running mate in 1944
would almost certainly become president
before that term of office had expired
but in fact he did not give much
attention to the selection of Harry
Truman he scarcely knew Truman it before
1944 and he didn't tell Truman some of
the most important facts he needed to
know to be a responsible president he
never told him about the Manhattan
Project about the atomic bomb project so
this was this was not Roosevelt's finest
hour he a more responsible leader I
think that that moment would have
stepped down to be sure it would have
taken a tremendous psychological effort
to give up power at the moment on the
eve of victory in this war it was
clearly the war was winding down by that
moment and he knew that he just held on
a little longer he would the the laurels
of victory would be his you can imagine
how psychologically difficult it was for
him to step down at that point but I
think a wiser and more responsible
leader would have or at a minimum would
have given much more attention to who
was going to be a successor and prepared
a successor better very little time left
if you could talk to someone in this
book that you were as you were going
through this you said I wish I could ask
them the questions they come to mind who
would it be well you know honestly I
think it probably would be because of
what we were just discussing to be Harry
Truman and my question would be why did
you allow James burns your Secretary of
State to delete from the Potsdam
Declaration what was in that original
draft which was the offer to the
Japanese that they could surrender on
the condition that they could preserve
the institution and the person of their
Emperor because it was is arguable that
the peace faction within the Japanese
government if they'd been guaranteed
that condition might have had a
sufficient sufficiently strong political
position that they would have
surrendered in July of 1945 before the
atomic weapons were used but we withdrew
that offer of that condition it was in
an early draft of the Potsdam
Declaration and they were confronted
with the choice of utter destruction of
their historic political system which
had the Emperor as a central part of it
or to fight to the finish and in those
circumstances the war party the
militarist party
still very strong in the Japanese
government said we will not throw in the
towel so it took the nuclear attacks
finally to convince them another book
for you next well I'm sure there are
more books in my future Brian but at
this moment I don't know what it's going
to be this is what the book looks like
David M Kennedy our guest freedom from
fear the American people in depression
and war in 1929 to 1945 thank you very
much for joining us thank you